welcome everyone it's great to see so
many of you here on a day on which we've
seen a historic political split with the
departure of seven MPs from Labour and
the formation of a breakaway party the
independent group that does sound a bit
like an online newspaper but apart from
that the no longer secret seven are
undoubtedly heading for the center
ground of politics and they are I
suspect the sort of people liberals who
we're discussing tonight in connection
with the rise of populism there are
populist in power in 11 European
countries whether it's Viktor Orban in
Hungary or La Liga and five star in
Italy 20 years ago the populist share of
the vote was in single digits now one in
four votes cast in action national
elections in Europe is for a populist
party look around the world and you can
point to gerbil scenario in Brazil or
Rodrigo Duterte
in the Philippines and I haven't even
mentioned Donald J Trump
there are populist on the old right and
the left of the political divide what do
they stand for and is it liberals who
brought about this shift in political
thinking well let's meet our panel who
are going to thrash this out Alif Shafak
is a political scientist by training
she's also an award-winning novelist and
the most widely read female writer in
Turkey her works been translated into 50
languages and she contributes to the FT
The Guardian and the New York Times and
other publications around the world John
Simpson is the BBC's world affairs
editor he's reported from a hundred and
forty countries interviewed a run around
200 world leaders and covered 46 Wars on
four continents Mathew Goodwin is
professor of politics and international
relations at Kent University and a
senior visiting fellow at Chatham House
he's been studying populist movements
for over a decade and his latest book is
the best-selling national populism the
revolt against liberal democracy and
Daniel Hannan is a prominent Rexach
campaigner and conservative MEP for
southeast England he's a prolific
journalist and the author of nine books
including what next how to get the best
brexit welcome to you all I think we
should begin by guessing our terminology
straight there's a lot to disagree about
just in terms of what it is we're
actually talking about so I want to ask
each of you briefly how do you define
populism Matthew well when I think of
populism national populism in particular
I think of a movement that wants to
prioritize the interests and the culture
of the nation-state and defender people
who it argues are being held in contempt
or neglected by distant and often
self-serving elites national interests
versus if you like elites that have are
unelected often yeah indeed you know I
think the distinction between left-wing
and right-wing populism for example left
wing populism would frame the people
along the lines of class solidarity
national populism would typically define
the people in terms of an ethnic
solidarity or an ethnic cultural
solidarity and that's the point of
distinction between the two but they
each argue that the elite is responsible
for all that has gone wrong in society
Alif well I think populism is the is the
wrong answer to some very real and very
genuine problems and it's a bit like a
bird with one wing it's an ideology but
because he can't fly with one wing it
needs another wing to support it and
usually the other wing is another
ideology in some cases that socialism
but in most of the cases it's
nationalism so it has to be accompanied
by something else but basically it's a
divisive ideology it divides the society
into two imaginary homogeneous camps the
people versus the elite and it acts as
if the people have a single voice have a
single will actually one of my favorite
stories is when you know as you know
with the French Revolution Robespierre
when they came to power in the name of
the people after a while he started
saying I am the people and after a while
he started slaughtering the people in
the name of the people while all of that
was happening
there was an interesting debate in
France they wanted to erect a statue of
the people on poor nerve but the problem
is how do you depict the people is it a
man as the woman is it old is it young
is it fat is it thin you know what is
the people so that illusion of a
homogeneous whole with regards to the
people is is a central thing and
secondly populism likes to act as if the
elite is also a homogeneous whole in
fact despite their rhetoric I think
populist do not have a problem with the
elite as long as they are the elite so
essentially it is an anti liberal
antipodal istic and eventually
eventually it will get there it is an
anti-democratic ideology Tanya Helen
yeah I think there's a lot in what Alex
just said the the classic definition of
populism that we're for real people
against an undefined elite is by its
nature very difficult to pin down it's
worth saying that this lack of
specificity also exists among its
critics so very often populism when
people try and pin it down simply means
something that other people like but
that I don't like which could be tax
cuts or tax rises could be different
policies on health care immigration but
it basically means a popular thing that
I think is wrong and therefore that's
why the word is spat out populist like
like someone who's like a like a
teenager who's mistakenly taken a swig
from the beer can that was being used as
the ashtray you know populist it doesn't
it doesn't get you very far
well I think is the the more interesting
question is who are the Liberals that
we're talking about well come to because
if I made just the for me liberal I mean
I would call myself a liberal in the
classic sense in that in the tradition
of you know jeaious mill and before that
were the proto liberals in John Milton
and John Locke and so on but I think in
the way that you introduced a trickler
liberal is now used to mean either kind
of Davos crony capitalists or a kind of
army of kind of complaining
you know outreach workers from Hackney
Council or something it isn't actually
used to me what the word literally means
which is the elevation of the individual
above a collective and an emphasis on
personal freedom I've got two for the
price of one there John how would you
define populism I I don't think the
populism is a proper ism I think it's an
expression that we use to describe a set
of emotions anger being a prime one
resentment and so forth which exists in
a number of different countries for what
I would think of as historical reasons
reasons created by the historical moment
through which we're living when you
actually speak to people like that for
Nacional in in in France or the the
alternative eh land and and and the
various other groups those that I have
spoken to they of course approve in
general terms of each other but there's
no real link
there's no populist kind of movement
that sweeps across America Britain the
the continent Turkey and so forth it's a
it's a response which is individual to
the individual companies countries and
of course like so many of these kind of
movements they've been used by people
who've got a real real serious agenda
whether Donald Trump has a real agenda
under except for himself and trumpism
III I don't know but in in this country
clearly well I mean let's actually
before we turn to this country let's
think about about Turkey it's being used
really essentially by Irwin for his own
political purposes just as populism in a
different sense in Russia is being used
by Putin for his own political purposes
and I I personally believe that the
brexit was
used a that brexit ears used populism
our version of populism to create the
kind of ends that they wanted to these
things will not last in historical terms
these big movements come up and they
fade away like in push ideas and in
France in the 50s but while they're here
they're very very serious indeed and we
cannot but take it take take account of
them so quite a few different ideas now
that we've got into the mix but a leaf
whilst let's stay with definitions for a
little a little bit longer liberal what
is a liberal do you agree with Daniels
definition I will answer your question
but as I was listening to the other
panelists I I want to make a confession
I have to share this with you as a
writer as a novelist I'm when they used
to know the writer who believes in
freedom of speech and the importance of
diversity and minority rights I'm very
used to defending liberal values and
liberal democracy in a country like
Turkey where sadly today there is no
freedom of speech and minority rights
are just constantly being trampled upon
and there's zero appreciation for
diversity so against that background and
they're used to defending liberal
democracy but I never thought you know I
would feel the need to defend liberals
and liberal values here in London in the
hearts of the country that has given us
some of the biggest and earliest liberal
political philosophers in world history
so it feels a little bit surreal for me
but we are where we are it's the year
2019 and we have to discuss this I think
it is going to be one of the major
debates in front of us so I'm glad that
we are organizing this and also I'm glad
that there's a nuance there are lots of
nuances in our on our panel because we
are being more and more pulled into
angry antagonistic tribes and we have to
find a way to smash the out to ality
that duality is not good for anyone and
we need to smash it wisely and calmly
and with utter respect for each other
even when we disagree that's one thing I
want to get out of my chest and the
second thing is you know I I think the
word liberal is today the most
misunderstood and misinterpreted word in
the English language as we're speaking
and nobody nobody wants to be called a
liberal you know I have friends in
America writers journalists academics
yeah nobody I'm very happy to call
myself in when it when you talk to these
people you know they they say don't call
me a liberal they want to be called
progressive so there's also a lot of
criticism coming from as you move from
one country to another the definition of
liberal changes and we need to bear that
in mind but of course most of the
criticism today comes from the right
yeah from the far right from the
populist ride and that attack is quite
vague so anyone and anything that
disagrees with their views is being
lumped together in a basket and labeled
as liberals and that won't - we need to
unpack that actually my my favorite
definition is by Rush Limbaugh this
far-right right-wing radio host he he
calls liberals the New York theater and
arts and croissants crowd so if you
happen they enjoy theater and arts and
literature and and the croissant next to
coffee
you too might be a liberal Matthew could
remember the last time you had a cross
off confessions are Syria but no in
terms of them being a liberal it Daniels
happy to sign up for others it's a term
of abuse in the context of this
conversation are these people these
croissants eating elites are they are
they the ones that should be blamed if
there is blame to be shared
perhaps you disagree with the idea of
blame for the rise in the populace
no I think liberals are partly to blame
for the rise of populism I've put my
cards on the table I think in particular
a certain strand within liberalism has
got things terribly wrong and I I would
take a slightly different view of this
evenings discussion I'm amazed that
we're nearly three years on from the
political shocks of 2016 with Trump and
brexit and all that we've seen else else
we're across the channel in Europe that
it's taken liberals in general terms so
long to reflect on why we're here and
what might have gone wrong with the
liberal project and I found it amazing
that liberals have thrown comfort
blankets all over themselves over the
last two or three years that all of
these seismic shocks are about social
media and big tech the legacy of the
financial crash what was written on the
side of a bus shadowy figures
controlling what we see on Facebook and
Twitter we just heard that populism is a
temporary blip it will be gone as
quickly as it's arisen we've heard that
populism is against everything that it's
not for something and the general view I
think has been just get this thing out
of here I don't want to think about it I
don't want to reflect about it I don't
want to take into account for example
the the possibility that it might have a
distinctive tradition of thought in its
own right that it might be offering
people an instrumental opportunity to
vote for some things such as national
art national identity such as traditions
such as belonging that it might actually
be rooted in some things that liberals
have got very wrong the economic
settlement being one the obsession with
individualism being another and so yeah
I mean I think that in general terms I'm
sure we can unpack parts of this
liberals are to blame for the rise of
populism well Daniel you're signing up
to liberalism and yet you're all this is
big sorry all this is being laid at your
door well that's why I was being very
strict about defining terms by liberal I
mean it in the exact sense in the
etymological sense of an emphasis on
freedom I don't mean it is anyone who
eats the cross on right that's that it
gets to the point where it means nothing
if you're just using it as a kind of
term to mean you know
elites but to answer the question are
liberals to blame I mean I think the
proximate cause for the changes in
politics that we've seen in much of
Europe and in the u.s. not in every
Western country has happen in Canada
hasn't happen in Australia but the the
rise of a more authoritarian type of
politics was the the financial crash or
rather the mistaken response to it
we saw the better part of a trillion
pounds taken from low and medium income
families through the tax system to bail
out some very wealthy bankers and
bondholders and rescue them from the
consequences of their own mistakes and
that seemed for the first time in my
life to vindicate watered until then
always struck me is a quite fringe left
position which is that the capitalist
system is really rig it's about the rich
staying rich it's not meritocratic for
the first time in my life there appeared
to be an element of truth in that
argument I think we will look back at
the bailouts as a calamitous mistake I
don't think that's the only thing going
on but I think that was the immediate
trigger whew you're saying this is about
family and flag and faith it's got
nothing to do with with perhaps 2008
that supplied those ideas have their
roots much further back I would agree
with that Dan that the financial crisis
exacerbated a lot of the divides that
we're now grappling with but the root
causes go back much further anybody
who's been looking at Europe knows that
this really began in the late 1970s
early 1980s and I think there's a lot of
truth to the claim that what we're
witnessing partly is a backlash to the
great liberal revolutions of the 1960s
and don't get me wrong I'm not here just
to bash liberals I think liberalism has
a obviously has achieved a lot of
wonderful things and you know I'm on
board with much of what liberalism is
about but every liberal in the room
would probably accept and if they don't
have be keen to hear why that their
ideology is increasingly being hijacked
by a strain of thought that has no
interest in the classical liberal
principles that Dan just referred to
that is absolutely obsessed with turning
everybody and everything into a victory
with historical and justices with
cultural appropriation with describing
everybody's a fascist everybody's a Nazi
we're not interested at all in having
any reasoned discussion whatsoever about
things that are happening today
and that strand of thought which has
sort of aligned itself to the liberal
left and hijack large parts of the
liberal left that is what is really
putting populism on steroids
Alicia FAQ I was gonna mention Steve
Bannon there who certainly identified
the idea that let's call it identity
politics was rather good for his brand
of populism if you want to call it that
I think there's there's a huge
conceptual chaos you know out there and
it's like a fog and everything and
everything is just just lumped together
we need to differentiate that classical
liberal philosophy that asks basic
questions and I think one of the most
important questions is who exercises
power over us individuals if it's the
government that government power should
never be absolute it should never be
totally uncontrolled there should be
checks and balances if it's a society
there should never be a tyranny of the
majority you know we should be careful
if there's more subtle forces of power
so just following that line of power
that classical liberal thinkers were
asking that is something else and what
we're talking about and what is
happening ever since 1970s onwards which
is neoliberalism is something completely
different we need to differentiate these
two things this market-driven
ideology and greed that has left the
that expects the public sector to
completely follow the rules of the
private sector and subsidize the private
sector that is something else so I think
we need to be careful when you say
Steven and it's not a coincidence that
Steve Annan and marina pan and many many
populous today they call themselves
Democrats they don't have a problem with
the word democracy all being called amok
that it's not a coincidence that the
populist party in Sweden is Swedish
populist party or in own slope in many
other countries
it is the liberal component of liberal
democracy at this stage they have a
problem with
so by that I mean rule of law separation
of powers free media independent
academia minority rights if you get all
these components out and you end up with
only the ballot box that regime as we've
seen in Turkey as we've seen in Hungary
and we're seeing in Poland and many
other examples right now that regime
turns into majoritarianism and once
majoritarianism kicks in from there into
authoritarianism it's a very short slide
so in a nutshell democracy needs those
liberal components and liberalism as a
philosophy needs democracy they
complement each other but what we are
experiencing is a divorce a divergence
of these two I'm sure we're talking
about whether liberals should be blamed
for the rise of populism but at the same
time is it is this what at least
describing the perhaps undermining of
democratic principles the rule of law
rights rational inquiry the open society
and so on
is that what makes liberals very
uncomfortable with the rise of populism
a desire to dismiss it because it's
somehow unpicking the fabric of of what
they see is the fundamentals of
democracy yeah well I'm sure that's true
the fact is though you asked us
originally what to give some definition
of liberalism and what we haven't yet
heard from anybody here is that
liberalism has given us 460 years of
peace and and prosperity on an
extraordinary scale the principle of
internationalism the growth of relations
between countries the linking of
countries together has proved to be the
greatest boon in in human history and
that we it's fading now it's always
starting to break up because liberalism
as I maintain populism will liberalism
is also starting to crack that's the the
way that human beings run their lives
and history is a is an extension of that
of
approach but the essence of what we've
had we've had it extraordinarily good a
billion people lifted out of out of
poverty in the last 15 years
why to continue why shouldn't that go on
why shouldn't her if you like that the
eruption of populism actually the chaos
that ensues create an opportunity sort
of you know Schumpeter creative
destruction and something new and and
vibrant emerges from it well perhaps it
will I mean no doubt no doubt it will
but what I'm trying to say is that the
the what's created this is that liberal
international cities out two things here
there is a kind of globalization that is
about lifting barriers allowing goods
and services to cross borders and that
indeed has lifted a billion people out
of poverty ziz achieving the most
extraordinary things all over Asia and
Africa and I agree has led to a but that
is a very and indeed hearin and and with
the the the biggest benefits
proportionately felt by the the poorest
people so it's something I we can all
agree is a good thing but we should be
careful before alighting that into and
therefore we want more powerful global
technocracy z-- with more and more power
to overall democratic governments
because that is the opposite of lifting
barriers out of people's way that is
about imposing barriers and often doing
so in policy areas which would not have
succeeded had they had to go through
national legislatures and so we
shouldn't make the mistake now this is
something that populist to her it was
very striking listening to marine lepen
that she alighted the two things
together all the time she was against
globalization both in terms of free
trade and free markets and in terms of
you know the European and and UN type
technocracy but they're two incredibly
different and I would argue antithetical
things because one is about liberating
people taking it making them freer from
state coercion and the other is about
imposing more rules what what I would
wear I think you and I might agree quite
strongly it is too much no no I'll try
not to make a mistake yeah but but
where I think we would agree is that
what has damaged the European project so
much in country after country and this
country more than most is was that drive
to unite Europe to put it together to
lift the lift the boundary raised the
boundaries to allow more and more
countries to come in a kind of European
izing principle which ran far ahead of
what they the citizens of the the
various European countries wanted or
were prepared to look up that in my
terms is not liberalism that's that's
that's bonapartism I mean less driving
these things through but this is Matt's
point no one since the referendum here
I've been in Brussels in the intervening
two and a half years and there are
various kind of approved acceptable
responses to Brick's it disbelief or
they'll never really do it
rage led astray by demagogues or all
kind of contempt just you wait you know
the one things we couldn't be so do the
one thing that nobody that nobody is
allowed to say in Brussels is oh I
wonder why they voted earlier I wanna I
wonder whether we might have behaved
differently ourselves I wonder whether
anyone else might vote leave if there so
there's been an absolute refusal to
engage in any self analysis cuz of
course it's much easier just to demonize
anyone that you disagree with I promised
we wouldn't spend the evening talking
about brexit but whilst we're here is it
populism is a vote for exit populist
part of it but but by no means all of it
just to give you one stat - to reflect I
mean only about 60 only about six in ten
levers had previously expressed any
interest at all in voting for the UK
Independence Party yet we're still
routinely told that this was essentially
a sort of populist project and we're
also routinely told I mean the you know
again to go back to my point about
comfort blankets that this is all about
you know big tech social media Robert
Mercer I mean you know the fact some of
the coverage of how people ended up
voting leave has just been remarkable to
me completely detached from the evidence
but but it's everything
happened in June 2016 that's basically
where the causal mechanism is to be
found and we've just completely lost
sight of the 30 or 40 years of research
that we have showing why Brits were so
Euroskeptic and why they felt that the
European project hadn't gone in the way
that they were initially told that it
was going to go and this has been
wrapped up into a broader problem for
liberals which I'll leave on the table
and we can reflect on which is this
tendency to absolutely catastrophize
everything everything's got to be
catastrophize brexit is populism Trump
is fascist there's absolutely no room
for nuance and the criticism of populism
as we've heard is it's binary and it
shuts things down into black and white
terms and that's that's correct but
liberals are very prone to doing the
same thing which is that there are no
legitimate grievances here everything is
evil everything is bad everything is
negative you see and I think that is
really the sad thing about our times we
are being constantly told that we have
only two options in everything you know
it's either this extreme or that extreme
and I think we have much more options
than that so you might be very critical
in my opinion we should be very critical
of populist demagogues who are
exploiting using and abusing some very
genuine grievances some very genuine
problems I make a difference between
them and the people who for very genuine
reasons because they have worries they
have concerns and they are right to have
concerns we need to talk about
inequality I mean finally inequality is
now at the center of our debates in the
year 2019 you know for such a long time
it was just on the on the fringes in to
1928 did 1% you know the richest 1%
could expect to capture around 15% of
the of the wealth of the income in 1928
in 19 mm mm 18 last year the same 1%
got more than 82 percent of the entire
money generated I'm talking across
Europe there is a huge inequality that
we need to talk about when I look at the
median household income in America
it has been clearly stagnant flats since
1985 so there's that dimension that huge
economic inequality but I'm not only
talking about that the anxiety the
anxiety of losing your job the anxiety
of not knowing what tomorrow might bring
the anxiety of thinking maybe my
children are not going to have the same
opportunities these are very real things
and no one has the right to little these
grievances do you know I respect those
grievances I might be very critical of
the populist demagogues who are
exploiting those buildings so I make a
distinction but if if we accept the idea
that this is these are issues that are
being exploited by populist demagogues
why do you think liberals haven't
alighted upon them Thomas Tom Frank
published lists and liberal in 2016
before the election of Trump and he
argued in that that the Democratic Party
which had once been the party of the
people had been kind of co-opted by a
managerial class and they were affluent
city dwellers suburbanite you know they
believed in opportunity in meritocracy
but actually they weren't willing to
give up what they already had in order
to make those things possible so this is
why we have to make a distinction again
when we're talking about elite it is not
elite it's elites the elites can be of
liberal values they might have a liberal
worldview the elites can be how can have
conservative views and as we are seeing
right now the elites can have also
populist views and just like Pareto
wrote a long time ago there's a
circulation of elites right now going on
we have to differentiate that there were
many liberals people on the Left people
on the right saying you know what this
inequality this is not fair this is not
right there have been many people
talking about that but their voices were
never heard by the elites by mainstream
politicians we need to make that
distinction but if we lump together
everything under the label of liberal we
won't get too far but there's something
else going on and this is a bit that I
really worry about which is there's a
YouGov poll two weeks ago that asks
remain as and levers would you be ok if
a relative brought home somebody from
the other political tribe okay so if a
lever brought home a remainer or remain
a brought home early
and 11% of leavers said I I would have a
problem actually if a relative brought
home a a remainer 37% of remainders said
I would have a problem if a relative
brought home a leader now how can we
explain the difference between the two
I'd suggest that what that gives us is
yet more evidence that we have the of
the fact that liberals can be as
intolerant of other political beliefs
and other ideas as populist can be and
so when I ask the question to you know
and I would say I'm generally a liberal
but but when I asked this question to
many of my liberal friends which is okay
after 2016 what are you willing to
concede are you going to concede some
major reforms on inequality are you
going to concede some immigration reform
are you going to concede that we need to
radically renew our political
institutions because they are not very
representative of the people who are
voting for populist and usual responses
nothing why should we concede we're not
going to concede anything and it's the
intolerance within a section of
liberalism that I think is going to make
this situation a lot worse but is that
not simply because the issues are so
serious this is not just an academic
question this is the the actual way in
which we live our lives and as you say
though the amount of money we earn
whether we're going to be able to feed
our children this is not something you
can just say well I take one view you
take the other I'm sure we can find a
middle ground this is serious stuff
so everyone everyone thinks that I mean
who wouldn't say I believe why my view
but but but Matt's point is there is an
extraordinary unwillingness from the
people who are the first to say we
believe in tolerance in accepting other
points of view actually to to respond
with incredulity whether or not when
another point of view is actually put
forward yeah I mean we're talking about
some of the more intolerant opinions
aren't we on the other side as well I
would give you a real world example and
I'm breaking all of our rules about not
talking endlessly about right
here's how the last two-and-a-half years
could have gone we could have had
remained politicians leaving London and
going to coastal communities and saying
hang on why have these areas not had any
inward investment for 30 years we could
have had people saying where should we
move the House of Lords and should we
replace it and make it democratically
elected we could have had people saying
which big institutions of financial
powers should we move to Gateshead or to
Wales or we should have people maybe of
asking asking why are only three percent
of MPs coming from a background of
manual work compared to 18 percent who
have only ever worked in politics we
could have had a really interesting
national discussion about where the
settlement has gone wrong and we haven't
what we had was a lot of people saying
get this thing out of here I don't want
to deal with it I don't want to reflect
on the grievances and they say well we
could have done that it's not true you
know I don't like so why didn't it
happen it's not true again we were
making a huge huge generalization so if
you ask that question in another country
formulated in a different way you might
have got some different answers let's
look at the discourse the rhetoric of
leaders people leading populist
movements in different countries what
are they saying there is a reason why
many of them like cultural wars populism
benefits from people being divided into
groups us versus them and the more angry
we get at each other the better it is
for the demagogues at the top so we need
to be very careful about not falling
into this trap there is a reason why you
know remembered one of trumps speeches
to me it was like Ardoin speaking I
couldn't believe my ears
he said the important thing is for us to
unify the people as for the other people
they don't matter right Nigel Farage
after the brexit vote one of the first
things he said was the real people the
decent people have spoken so if there's
a real people then there's also the
opposite on unreal people who are they
the I can give you many examples there's
always a division between you know these
people are better pure
these are the other people we have to be
very careful
I'm not by you doing any of that but I'm
saying that the obsession with the
populist demagogues is is it's
distracting everybody the populist
demagogues are important but we are
obsessing about them what my question to
you is how do you respond seriously to
the grievances that are fueling pop I'm
telling you I think the system is not
sustainable this tool even the the left
versus right divisions we need to move
beyond that we need we need to reform
our politics we need to reform our tax
system we need to talk about inequality
sincerely honestly there are lots of
things that need to change and also
there are some other elements that we
haven't touched upon like demographics
you know we need to talk about anxiety I
understand anxiety so well maybe maybe
it's because I am an anxious person
myself I know how one form of anxiety
triggers other forms of anxiety yeah but
it's not going to happen because of the
anger that's created within our
societies don't move beyond our echo
chambers it is our duty to communicate
to connect what I'm doing that is to
take seriously the reasons that people
themselves if people vote for Trump the
pendulum the classic response is to say
what were they really voting for let's
diagnose some subconscious reason that
they weren't aware of to do with
economic decline and that is of course
exactly the kind of patronizing attitude
that has driven people into being angry
in the first place they work they let
let's take seriously what they say
they're interesting and see whether
there is a way of addressing it is the
underlying assumption in what both of
you are saying that the populace have
the answer I don't think the populist
movements have the answer I agree with
some of what you are saying that they do
bend the question to a different outcome
absolutely but there are unquestionably
some very big legitimate grievances that
people have over the representativeness
of our political institutions over the
economic settlement and over the pace of
demographic change
I mean why cry in respond
you know in terms of where Europe is
going over the next 50 50 years to our
to 100 years contrary to the idea that
we're witnessing a sort of puja deist
sequel everything that I see that's
driving support for populism I've read
pretty much every study that this being
says there are two ingredients to this
one is very strong distrust of
established politicians but by far the
most important is anxiety over the pace
and scale of demographic change now
those two things as liberal politicians
increasingly turn in on themselves and
become less representative and as our
societies continue to experience very
rapid demographic change those things
will sharpen so if we don't begin to
answer the questions soon they're not
actually they may begin to outflank us
to a much greater what we're talking
about is immigration is black people
coming from Africa and arriving in
Europe and European nations coming to I
mean these these were real serious
issues which I mean I think it's only
fair to say that the liberal instinct as
it were was to was to cover over not to
notice I mean the essentially the Blair
right response was to say it's actually
good for you in the long run who do you
think's going to serve you in in in
cafes who's gonna do the hard work who's
gonna clean the the the windows we have
to have these people in and I don't want
to hear anything from you that that is
critical because that's a it's a bad
response and that is certainly true
there's no doubt about it
you're a really interesting question
which is do the populous have the answer
which which no one has tried to answer
yet so let me have a go right the
problem is these problems are created we
all agree about you know that we have
sense that there's a dislocated elite
that people don't feel represents them
and then I would say this has been the
story of almost every populist movement
going back to the Grassi brothers in
Rome what they say is when we get our
people in it will be different because
we will have
right authentic genuine view and they
will be different from these out of
touch shadowy half foreign elites right
and of course what happens every time is
they get in and they use the power of
the state to reward a different set of
followers but nothing is actually solved
starting now the real solution I would
argue is instead of getting a different
bunch of people into smash at the levers
of control is to try and defuse power
decentralized dispersed democratize
power so that the issue of who is
controlling becomes less of a problem
yes but Daniel if that were the kind of
solution that comes out of human nature
and so forth we would have seen it again
and again and again at the gray key and
everybody down to earth the one would
would behave better the fact is they
don't those kind of those kind of
movements do not throw up that kind of
response no of course they don't that's
that's that's why the correct thing it
seems to me for a responsible
policymaker is to say instead of giving
people a choice between as it were
mackerel and lepen or a choice between
Clinton and Trump can't we do better
can't we have an option which is about
restoring the supremacy of actual
liberalism the supremacy of the
individual the super embassy of
localized decision-making so that the
the issues that drove populism in the
first place the sense of
disenfranchisement are addressed the
year before the the freedom house I'm
sure you've seen the results when they
looked across the east and west
everywhere 72 countries have been
sliding backwards in 72 countries civil
liberties political rights are today in
danger you might say well some countries
have made progress as well yes 35
countries have made progress but twice
as many have been sliding backwards my
motherland is one of those countries and
for me this debate is not an abstract
theoretical debate I have seen it happen
first gradually and then with a
bewildering speed I have seen what
happens when populace come to power in
Turkey in Hungary in Poland how they
place their own cronies in
Constitutional Court
change
the entire judiciary you know that's one
of their first names how they changed
the electoral system and then the media
becomes the enemy of the people there
are of course differences as you move
from one country to another but there
are amazing similarities which we should
be aware of yeah and and that is why I
think we should all be concerned whether
you're voting labour or or toy is it is
beyond that you know what we're facing
is losing the coexistence is losing the
harmony that has been binding us
together and just to give you an example
the distortion is so deep when there
when the elections were going on in
France maybe you've seen macron like
many other politicians he goes out on
the street he's talking to people and he
goes into the fish factory he's talking
with with the workers and he sees an eel
a fish and he starts cutting the the eel
with a worker and they work together and
then of course his hands I'm messy you
know
dirty he goes on washes his hands right
that's it that's the video a far-right
side took that video and edited the
video so they took out the eel the fish
with that detail is gone and they took
the previous scene and replaced it with
a posterior scene so that in this new
video micron goes to factory he shakes
hand with a worker he looks at his hands
and he says yeah I've just you know
attached the worker and then he goes and
washes he says the reason why I'm
mentioning this is because we are losing
the truth the norms you know we can
always have disagreements but if the
truth is being eroded that should
concern all of us this kind of
systematic distortion is very new one
quick same question before we open out
to the floor is the legacy which is I
think where you're going away for this
of populism to weaken democracy
ultimately oh this country I think has
much less of a problem than almost
anywhere in Europe we're very unusual in
not having an anti-immigrant populist
party in the main chamber of our
legislature we're also according to all
the opinion polls the most Pro
immigration country in Europe in the
sense that when people are asked to you
take a positive or a very positive view
we come out above all the other big
countries in fact in all the other
countries in the the data that I've seen
and the interesting thing to me and it
runs so totally contrary to the media
narrative over the last two years that a
lot of people in the audience will shake
their head disbelievingly when I say
this but the the data is there we've
become much more pro-immigration
over the last thirty months so your
question I was asking I was saying is
that is the legacy of all of this
whatever the causes whatever the way in
which it manifests itself ultimately to
undermine the democratic ideals by which
we have lived and voted for the last
however many years I mean the problem is
not democracy with all of the the horror
stories that we're hearing from Turkey
and I I completely agree with that if
there was a slow decline and then from
about 2013 a sudden collapse but the
last thing to go has been democracy that
the problem with Turkey is not that
there are no elections or that or it's
it's that it's that the the rule of law
and the liberal order that sustains
democracy has been hollowed out that's a
very narrow definition of democracy
there is the election voting is yeah
well yes okay it's a narrow but I think
that's what democracy means well it will
say those institutions and the rule of
law and justice and various democracy
doesn't just mean a good thing if you
can have a democracy with bad outcomes
democracy doesn't mean something I
happen to agree with so in Hungary in
Turkey in Poland there have been all
sorts of moves away from a liberal order
but I don't think anyone is arguing
certainly not in Hungary in Poland until
very recently in Turkey that the
elections were not you know what were
invalid that there was massive something
very inherent a populist ideology if you
think you represent the people anyone
who challenges you is the enemy of the
people you know that mentality is right
there from the very beginning and this
is why people like Kaczynski for
instance in Poland he calls the poles
who dare to criticize him those are the
bad poles that have the gene of treason
betrayal in their in their blood he says
you can easily turn into a traitor in
the eyes of the populace Davis was
showing us with those statistics earlier
and the reverse people can be every bit
as intolerant the other way around okay
on that note I'm gonna let you come back
in a minute
open the floor up to questions lots of
hands going up already I'm just gonna
wait to find people with microphones
this lady at the front here I just like
to add something to watch on citizens
it's going to turn into a question John
Simpson said that people kind of ignored
the effects of mass movement into
britain from from the EU countries loads
and loads of statistics in in the kind
of right thinking put in the PM pass off
press used to say well yes this the
advent of all these workers doesn't harm
the economy except for the wages at the
very bottom and I would ask the panel
what special place in hell is reserved
for people who who are so cavalier about
the very mo the most vulnerable in our
society okay thank you and there was a
yes earlier on the discussion Matthew
Goodwin got dangerously close to
actually answering the question posed by
the debate which is shoot to be and how
can we blame liberals for the rise of
populism you're all addicted to going on
about how awful these populist leaders
are we all know that what's interesting
is to what extent are liberals to blame
for this occurrence this pan national
occurrence I'd love to hear the panel
just address that point please
[Music]
and there with one more I think just
over there thank you I wonder what the
panel felt about the impact of issues
like climate change in our collective
future population growth and so on on
the rise of populism and the links
possibly with my increased migration
that is likely to happen in the future
thank you very much so should we should
we there a special place in hell for
those who were rather cavalier about the
impact of mass migration on the
lowest-paid should we blame liberals
we've been pussyfooting around I'm told
and climate change and population grows
how much in a sense we can't get away
from them how much are they going to
keep driving these political movements I
think that's what I understood your
question to be let me take the second
one
I answered briefly in terms of the
financial crisis but I I was gonna go on
to say I think there is something much
deeper as something whose explanations
are to be found as much in the field of
psychology as of politics a lot of the
liberal ideals which we were taught
which I guess most people in this room
were taught from the day they went to
school don't come naturally the idea
that you should assess an idea on its
own merits rather than on the basis of
whether you like the person saying it is
actually quite a counterintuitive one
we've all had to learn to do it and
we've internalized it but it is not
something that comes naturally and
people very easily revert to the kind of
earlier tribal heuristic of I don't like
you so everything you're saying must be
wrong people have a tendency to
conspiracy theory and you know in in
places where you don't have that the
closest correlation for where do you
find conspiracy theories is how much
higher education is there in that
country this is something that has to be
educated out of people if you like so I
wonder whether we've not lived through a
quite abnormal period a liberal period
in which there is emphasis on individual
rights and human rights and there is
also an emphasis on the norms and
courtesies that make for a civil
political discourse but I wonder whether
that isn't the unusual bit so when
people say you know there's never been
such a hostile climate in an American
presidential election as now I mean of
course there has you know what about
what about Abraham Lincoln's election in
1860 or what about you know the
Jeffersonian nation
hundred or whatever maybe disquieting
thought maybe it was the late 20th
century that was the unusual period
because there was next tunnel enemy in
the form of the Cold War because there
was a surprising and indeed in America a
unique homogeneity everyone having
watched the same three TV channels and
gone to the same schools and study the
same things if we want to preserve the
basic Enlightenment values of empiricism
and value you know the emphasis on
freedom and an individual force and so
on we have to teach them and when I said
at the beginning I'm happy to call
myself a liberal in the tradition of
Locke and Mill and Milton and so on
I don't think that those works are being
nearly as widely taught as they once
were and if they're not people are not
going to Intuit these ideas because they
don't come naturally they're running up
against a million years of evolution so
unless we work hard to inculcate in
people the value the difficult value of
listening to people that you don't like
because they might still have something
useful to say anyway don't expect them
to find their own way to that conclusion
masse well if I can weave some of the
questions together I recently finished
reading Hillary Clinton's book what
happened and I got to the end and I
realized she still doesn't know what
happened in the sense that it was all
about what had happened during that
campaign and there was absolutely no
reflection to speak to your question
about the bigger challenges that are
facing the liberal left and one of those
challenges is linked to the other
question about mass migration which is
that people do not only evaluate the
health of the nation in terms of GDP and
this has run through the Trump campaign
the brexit campaign it runs through
Europe that this utter obsession with
reducing every debate down to economic
costs and benefits is at odds with how
most people view not only their national
community but also how they view life
without getting too deep we are not
wired to be self-interested lemmings in
the way that many of our commentators
would would have us believe
and that's being revealed quite
dramatically over the last few years and
again the fact that we have an answer
jewel the leading question as as
detailed as perhaps we should have done
is because I still think we're in a
state of shock collectively that people
haven't yet been prepared to pull the
curtains back and say okay actually
where did we go wrong here and my worry
is that's now being overtaken by
interestingly that new ideology that I
mentioned and nobody really picked up on
which is the way in which liberalism of
the sort that Dan describes is being
hijacked very quickly by people who
claim to be liberals but in fact are not
liberal at all the more in common
rapport that was recently released by
the Joe Cox foundation the hidden tribes
report showed this very nicely that
there are three types of liberal
liberals in in the u.s. and one of those
tribes which is the most noisy the
progressive liberals are not interested
in compromise they're not interested in
consensus not interested in making
society more fair or equal they're
interested in defining everybody as a
victim and going on and on about
historical injustice to the point that
then they're surprised when white
Americans say well gee hang on I'm a
victim too maybe I'd quite like to get
on board with this Donald Trump guy
who's telling me I'm I'm affecting my
worry for liberals now is there's no
unifying myth anymore there's no
unifying story anymore there's nothing
that is about bringing people together
it's all about differentiation it's all
about sub dividing people into
constantly evolving and new categories
and groups and then we sit around and we
say well why is a communitarian and
collectivist ideology on the march by
gee I don't understand because we're
just obsessed with turning everybody
into if you lay those criticisms at the
door of liberals why shouldn't you lay
similar criticisms at the door of
populace who have equally are as we've
talked about other in talking about
defining themselves against other groups
it works both ways yeah I mean I think
populist
are ruthless are manipulative are
conceited are very quick to turn
questions into an ethnic or see all
questions through through an ethnic lens
but in a way I'm less interested in the
populace themselves like you we all know
who Donald Trump is I don't find Trump
particularly interesting what I find
more interesting is the is the complete
failure of the Democrats to renew their
ideological vision and their message I
mean this even today the new party or
the new faction in Parliament what
struck me about reading their statement
this morning was it's completely absent
of any idea
there's just no idea there's nothing
other than we don't really like brexit
that's it there's no passionate new case
for yeah how to fix a settlement how to
renew the nation how to renew the
international order there's just nothing
there and it's Dan said I maybe we're at
the point you know without sounding to
macro about it all but we've had human
civilization for 5,000 years we've had
liberal democracy for a hundred years
maybe we are at the point where actually
an ideology is now just entering into
its twilight year gosh there's a big
John I I think the gentleman who asked
us to actually address the question
that's hanging so heavily over I has is
absolutely right I mean we we haven't I
personally do not think it's liberalism
or liberals who are responsible for the
rise of populism I think it's the
without wanting to sound too Marxist
about it I think it's the march of
history I think it's the direction of
history we saw something of the same
thing in the 1880s and 1890s in the
early 1900s a sense of that human
existence was was it was improving all
the time when in fact it it wasn't and I
thought one of the things that Matthew
said that was really really attractive
and it answers why debate it addresses
itself to the lady who asks about the
particular
a place in hell of course we should have
responded by by trying to work out what
was wrong where did we go wrong and
redress it and change the way that our
politics are operating that just a human
nature it's not what we're doing and if
you could examine all of this sub speck
yay I turn it artists like God would
looking down you'd say oh god they're
added well I suppose God doesn't say Oh
God does he but but they're there
they're at it again
they work themselves up to a point where
they doing extremely well and then they
they screw it up for themselves because
their cloth eared and they don't listen
Aleve I also try to connect the the
questions you know until not that long
ago when when you look at the political
parties the MPs politicians many of them
those were who were on the Left had very
strong roots in trade unions trade union
culture the working class and when you
look at the politicians on the right
side many of them had very strong
connections with the agricultural sector
they came from such families or they
knew people who are connected with that
community more and more we see those
bonds weakening so much so that today in
this country only 3% of MPs are coming
from a relatively lower class background
less privileged background to put it
more bluntly I think we need to talk
about how education is a major divide in
this country we need to talk about the
class barriers in other words more and
more mp's politicians on both sides of
the ideological spectrum are becoming
similar to each other and becoming more
and more disconnected from the people I
think that is one of our major problems
another thing is this massive inequality
that we need to talk and it is
direct result of neoliberalism that was
started in 1970s onwards and got worse
and worse this entire idea of the
markets you know unrestrained the the
corporate world how that benefits we
need to talk out about you know and to
me this is a very liberal question we
need to trace the power you know who
exercises power over us is a very
legitimate question a second thing that
has been changing dramatically is
demographics
this is affecting countries on the
periphery of Europe such as Bulgaria
where we are expecting a 27% decline in
the population in the year 2050 that
also means an anxiety you know people
are becoming worried that they are going
to become a minority in their own
countries this is also a major question
in America in many states today
including in Texas and California the
white segment of the population has
turned into a minority is this not only
because of immigration it's also related
to birth rates among different groups
but in the Year 2044 America is most
probably going to become a minority
majority country maybe for me this is
not a concern but I can understand that
this can be a concern for many people
who are living very different lives so
we need to talk about demographics and
one thing that we have not sadly not
touched upon hopefully on another debate
is the social media we need to talk
about that you know the social media
everything our political debate has
migrated online whether we like it or
not we need to talk about big data we
need to talk about micro targeting this
is very real and especially after the
year 2012 13 when tech companies turned
into advertisement companies when they
allowed us you know when they allowed
big firms to target us depending on our
purse you know inclinations lit so if
you have anti-semitic inclinations yeah
you used you will be getting more and
more anti-semitic messages if you have
Islamophobic maybe a potential you get
more and more of that the algorithm of
YouTube that does not make
the difference whether you're selling
extremism or an eczema cream it's a it's
a it's a property like you know any
other so what I'm trying to say is that
whole shifts that whole transformation
has also affected our political debates
okay I got to bring Matthew in briefly
because you did talk about tack a little
bit but I think you're quite cynical I
think about the extent to which
algorithms are dictating our views yeah
so well I'm open to the idea that what
big tech social media is doing is
exacerbating polarization but what we've
been given is a different line which is
it's a causal factor in why people voted
in Trump or brexit and that is
incredibly misleading I've read every
study for example that's been done on
the UK referendum and you would be
incredibly hard pressed to put a
convincing case together to suggest that
what people were seeing on Facebook and
Twitter was as influential as we've been
led to believe
and we've also conveniently forgotten
the fact in this conversation about big
tech is that it's a very low trust
environment only 30% of people trust
what they see on social media people are
not these kind of you know non
inquisitive lemmings walking around
being told how to vote by certain
politicians was the first elections in
America where the majority of the waters
got their information through social
media but but I think we need to clarify
one thing what we're experiencing right
now is a very complex phenomenon and it
would be a mistake to try to reduce it
to one single course I'm not saying the
social media is the cause but we need to
talk about the shifts in social media
and it's not only people are on the on
the liberal left are saying this many
conservative thinkers like David Frum
they are expressing their worry that
almost 30% of America is living in an
information ghetto you know that should
concern all of us where do we get our
knowledge from we're all being so
nostalgic about the previous age when
you only read the Guardian or when you
only read the Daily Mail you really were
in a guess now
because of nostalgia but here's that
here's the difference this has nothing
to do with nostalgia you know when you
read The Guardian or the Sun as a reader
we know more or less what to expect we
have our own personal filter the
algorithm of YouTube gives the
impression of being neutral the you know
we all accept that the printing machine
had a huge impact on you know on the
culture on politics on society but we
find it very difficult to accept that
the the revolution these changes in
trust in communication technology are
also having because I get very citizens
we all of us doesn't matter which party
we're voting for but we need to keep an
eye on social media okay I get that so
that was a great discussion I want to
get some more questions in I'm gonna go
on the left number four over there yes
there's a gentleman there so anybody
then there's a gentleman here number two
yes great okay my question is for math
you could win specifically you gave a
stat that well liberals were three times
as likely to be upset if some of the
opposite camp came home to dinner
any idea why okay and it was gentlemen
up here LF you just said YouTube sort of
promote that algorithms to be neutral
but I'd argue that the algorithms are
actually promoted tell you kind of give
you the idea that the impression that
they understand what you want how do you
feel that that is sort of promoting
Popular's and then liberalism okay any
more on that side yes one more there
number two thank you hi yeah that's one
question I had which was is what we're
looking at as a dearth of quality of
politician
if you over the last over the last 10
years I can't think of any true
strategic thinker that's come out with
breakthrough policy the referendum is a
perfect opportunity for people to think
about how to be strategic and how to
reinvent the future of this country and
clearly no one's done it quite yet okay
Matthew I'm gonna go with you first
because there was that very specific
question
why do you think liberals are three
times as likely to be upset it's so on
of the opposite of persuasion comes home
there was crushing about algorithms and
YouTube and the dearth of quality
politicians well on the the first
question we haven't talked at all really
about some of the achievements of
liberalism and one of the achievements
has been some pretty remarkable social
change in a very short period of time to
give you one example in about 50 years
in the US the percentage of Americans
who have gone from disapproving of
intergroup marriage to approving in
about 50 years has gone from 90 percent
disapproving to about 90 percent
approving in an incredibly short space
of time we forget how quickly views can
change but but now we're faced with
findings similar to the one I mentioned
in the UK where you have nearly 40% of
Democrats saying they would have a
fundamental problem if a relative
brought home a Republican to to have
dinner and you know introduced a
Republican into the family which is a
reflection of how political polarization
is quickly I think eclipsing some of
those traditional arenas of of division
why is it happening this is the elephant
in the room I think that runs through
this debate which is that we now have a
growing number of studies some of which
I shared on on Twitter and it's always
met with what I call the silence which
is nobody really really sort of engages
with with them but that we have a
growing number of experimental study
suggesting that liberal orientated
people are very intolerant can
very intolerant of political views and
beliefs that are different to their own
and it may well be a fact that we've it
may be to do with what we've hinted
towards that the self selection into
high prestige high status educational
institutions also exacerbates the
tendency to self-select into social
networks that don't particularly
challenge views alongside the fact that
to be frank a lot of liberals have
benefited from a media social and
economic consensus that has largely
supported and defended their values and
I think over the last two or three years
a lot of people who were used to feeling
like winners in at least in the
political world have for the first time
in their lives started to feel like
losers and I think that's been
especially challenging and I think it's
brought out a lot of a lot of those
underlying psychological dispositions
but the research on that I think is out
there and I think we do need to take it
quite seriously John I'd like
particularly to address the gentlemen
who felt that politicians are a lower
and lesser quality now and there was
quite a lot of applause of blood about
it I I've been reporting on on British
politics since really about 1970 for a
time I was the BBC political editor in
the early days of the Thatcher
government first Thatcher government my
my impression is not that we nowadays
have midgets and dwarves my lord to say
them I don't know we're not allowed we
don't have politicians of restricted
stature compared with the giants that
want be strode the the nation not true
what has changed is the way in which we
perceive them and we're allowed to
perceive them Harold Wilson was a man
who
surrounded himself with with with
defenses which made it really difficult
to see him as a as a person same was
true of of Harold Macmillan although he
was just slightly before before my time
weirdly it was Margaret Thatcher that
that did away with a lot of that that
kind of distance that politicians placed
between themselves and and and ordinary
people we were permitted to see Margaret
Thatcher at a closer a closer to then
for instance we had with her
predecessors and as as it's gone on so
we've been able to see our politicians
more and more closely we've stuck them
under the microscope we've seen every
single failing and fault that they have
but believe me as somebody who's who's
gone the gone the rounds with them
there's not much difference between
politicians today and politicians in the
1960s it's just that we're not allowed
we weren't allowed to examine them as
closely as we are now bit of a defense
line I'm gonna make Dan wait at least
I'm gonna pick up on that question as
well there's a story that I like
actually about John McCain and obviously
I have lots of I had lots of
disagreements with his politics but also
respect for for the man himself and
while he was running his campaign
against Obama at the time there are lots
of times when people in the audience
stood up and they would say all kinds of
things about Obama and he would
challenge his own audience and in one of
those occasions in a town hall a woman
stood up and she said that she did not
find Obama trustworthy because he's a
Muslim he's an Arab he's not trustworthy
so he used these she used those words
and John McCain's response was madam
first of all what you're saying is
misinformation you know you have been
guided by misinformation and secondly
Obama is a decent father he's a decent
citizens he's a decent politician we
just happen to have disagreements on
fundamental issues and that is what this
campaign is about so the reason why I'm
mentioning this is because that kind of
agreement and respect for basic
democratic norms is what we're losing
today and this is the danger of populism
that we need to underline you know this
constant hatred this constant tension
and questioning the very truth the very
foundations of liberal democracy so I am
as critical as you are if do I agree
with the proposition that is the liberal
elite are the elites themselves whether
they are conservative or liberal or
populist the elites to be held
responsible for all this inequality and
how they turned a blind eye to all that
you know unfairness that has been going
on for decades yes I am very critical of
that but do I agree with the proposition
that we can generalize we have to be
very careful about that because what
we're losing right now is this very
basis you know the basic norms but at
the time many politicians with integrity
were aware of and tried to defend with
regards to the algorithms I find it a
very important issue I lived in America
I lived in Boston Michigan and then
Arizona I lived in Tucson very close to
Mexican border it was just i opening
experience for me after 9/11 and this
was a time when radio hosts were saying
the Liberals have four pillars of evil
they would say the the media science
academia and one by one we're going to
replace it that kind of discourse
started in in early 2000s you know to
build an alternative digital world out
there to build an alternative media to
build an alternative science there's
there is an effort there that has been
going on for a long time and just to
give you a few numbers the number of
people following White's
supreme
Syst white nationalist accounts on
twitter between the year 2012 and 2015
increased 600 percent in America all of
that should worry us because of the way
how we are bombarded by you know we
don't even know how to deal with a
bombardment of information but now we
are also bombarded with misinformation
I'm gonna briefly I'll stand to talk
about we just can't get the politicians
these days and then I would say we're
running out time is your fault right I
mean in a democracy you get the
politicians you deserve I'm soon gonna
be able to say our fault because I
fought my last election I'm glad to say
and will be returning to civilian life
but I perhaps presuming on that outgoing
status I'm gonna do something which is
never popular which is to mount a
defense of my existing not for much
longer profession very often when we
complain about politicians what we're
complaining about is the inability to
work out the contradictory impulses that
exist in any polity in any state you
know we want to have lower taxes and we
want to have higher spending on our pet
projects we want to have less
immigration and we want to have the
growth that comes from more integration
we we don't want any new houses built
near us but we want to be able to afford
houses and the politicians just don't
listen
but of course they can't reconcile
fundamentally irreconcilable ambitions
and of course it's part of their
function just to be the people that get
blamed
in that situation I want to say one
other thing following on from Eric's
last point about the the the the number
of people now following white
supremacist websites I think one of the
issues that is driving the current rise
of authoritarianism is our obsession
with identity politics
in general and racial politics in
particular and the this idea that the
outright and the woke left a kind of
opposites I don't think really stands up
to scrutiny they're both determined to
see everything through the prism of race
and it seems to me the most
fundamentally a liberal ideal of all
whether it comes from the far right or
whether it comes from people who call
themselves program
to say that the most important way to
judge someone is not by their kindness
or their intelligence or their courtesy
or their gender or steal their courage
but by their physiognomy and I'm gonna
stop you there because it is a whole
another conversation while I know that
intelligent squared are gonna have very
soon so do come along to that one
because I want to get some more
questions in yes number one and there's
also one up front here and one at the
back that you will seemingly criticized
liberalism as well as populism quite
justified Lee so populism I'm sure
everyone agrees and as a young leftist
and political person I personally feel
very disillusioned by all the political
options when it comes to voting I'm like
who do I vote for and I'm sure there's I
know a lot of my peers agree with me on
that front so if we can't vote for
populism which is appealing in many ways
for disillusioned young people because
it offers a sense of unity in harmony as
you said do you think that liberalism
needs to be redefined or that we need a
positive or termina tip to populism
there was another one at the back
somewhere yeah and thank you for the
healthy debate around liberalism and
populist within a nation-state I think
one thing I'd like to get your viewpoint
on is an external viewpoint when you
look at the rise of populism across the
nation states and perhaps to frame it
into a question do you think you would
rely on but thinking the ideology of
liberalism to help ease the tensions of
rising populism across nation states
okay and there was I know there's one
more hand up here
mine's quite quick one said do you think
we're at risk of over complicating the
debate by turning into this kind of
ideological thing and actually another
definition for Popular's and the
liberalism is poor people and rich
people and actually this simple kind of
inequality growth is driving more
populist and through simple kind of
economic factors great okay so someone
who's disillusioned by the political
operative options does the liberalism
need to be redefined or should there be
a positive alternative to populism
should we rely on the ideology of
liberalism to fight populism or
another way of thinking about all of
this simply poor versus rich John I'm
gonna go with you first
I mean these are such different subjects
aren't they it's bit difficult sort of
get a one-size-fits-all answer
I do think perhaps I can take they quit
the first of the questions but no I do
think and believe me once I mean it must
be impossible you know to to to even
conceive of it but I was young and I and
I think that there is something often in
us when we are young which is really
terribly kind of self-indulgent and soft
about it politics is as we are always
being told the art of of having to
choose between difficult solutions and
possible solutions and I think it's
important for young people not that
they'll do it not that I did it to to to
kind of man up about it and accept that
you're never going to find perfection I
mean this was what what happened with
with with Jeremy Corbyn that people
thought that he was perfect and then
surprise surprise they found that like
everybody else he had to make
compromises and that then the some of
the support at least started to fall
away that's that's a really naive
approach to politics you have to accept
that these things are difficult that
they're awkward and that there isn't a
kind of 100 percent solution and never
never will be dan if we can keep what
ask all of you to keep it fairly brief
Stanley Baldwin was Prime Minister for
much of the interwar period very uh
Nydia logical on dogmatic Tory and he
was asked towards the end of his life
whether he'd been influenced by any
particular thing
and rather surprisingly because he
wasn't the sort of chap who read books
very much he he said yes yes I was I was
very influenced as a young man by the
teaching of Sir Henry Maine and it was
through reading his works that I came to
understand that all human progress is a
move from status to contract and then he
paused frowning and said well was it the
other way around now the story is a is a
little illustration of how even most
brilliant ideas become over smooth
through overuse but just pause for a
second and think about what that means
the move from status to contract that
instead of having our relations with
each other mediated by birth or caste or
tradition we are all treated as
autonomous individuals able to make
free-standing contracts one with another
on an issue-by-issue basis that for me
is the essence of a liberal society for
me a tea that what a what an open
society rests on and it has elevated our
species to a pinnacle of wealth and
happiness that would have recently been
unimaginable
if by liberalism we mean defending that
supremacy of the individual then it's
still the best idea on the market if
instead of allowing liberalism to be
corroded by all of these ideas of
identity politics and you know elitism
and so on if we just restore our
confidence in the core idea that the
individual should be elevated above the
collective and that the rules should be
elevated above the rulers then I think
that is the answer both to the populist
challenge and indeed to the elitism
which spurred it in the first place
Alif no memory is an interesting thing
and it's an important part of of this
entire political debate actually one of
the most interesting researches that was
done recently asked people of different
age groups on both sides of the Atlantic
how important is it for you to live in a
democracy and interestingly people above
a certain age answer that question in a
more positive way they said it was
crucial for them to live in a liberal
democracy among the Millennials it was
it was a bit more tricky the results and
a large portion of them said maybe it
wasn't that important my worry is when I
look at the numbers in the UK in Germany
in u.s. people who are now situating
themselves especially among young people
on the far right or the far left those
numbers are increasing you know in the
UK it has doubled in a place like Sweden
it has tripled why because people are
the solutions they're not happy with
this status quo obviously and they're
there right not to be happy so those
grievances those resentments are very
real and we have to deal with those
problems honestly and frankly and
without any delay but at the same time I
think we need to understand what we have
here you know liberal democracy
especially if you come from a country
where there has never been a proper
liberal democracy maybe you understand
its value better and there are many
people all across the world in Brazil in
Venezuela in Turkey for them being a
liberal or being a Democrat it's not a
theoretical question people people risk
their lives you know for voicing these
opinions and unfortunately even in
Europe this is happening as you know the
Liberal mayor of over town in Poland has
been killed recently again in Poland 14
women they recently have been arrested
and their crime is to open just a banner
that says no to fascism they were beaten
by ultra national school
and then the police came and instead of
arresting the ultra-nationalist groups
the police arrested the women and now
they're going to be they have to go
through a trial so in many parts of the
world it is not easy to say I'm a
liberal I'm a Democrat and to voice
these opinions and what I'm trying to
say is maybe we have to appreciate the
system that we have definitely liberal
democracy is not a bed of roses but it
is the it's a better system that any
other regime that humanity could come up
with so far but what I'm referring to
here is things like rule of law
separation of powers free media minority
rights these are the things we need to
protect at the same time we need to
renew this system because it's not
working we need to deal with inequality
while protecting the basics we can
reform and renew the system and we must
do that now Matthew very briefly cuz
I've now crashed the bulletin and ruined
the arches or something so very brief
usual to address those quick questions
and then we'll have one quick little
run-through at the end it's all in the
book it's all in the book that's good
okay I get ask each of you before
Matthew sells the book about the front
to come back to the main question I
think we have addressed much of this as
we've gone along but just in 30 seconds
each do you blame liberals for pot the
rise of populism and is populism here to
stay
dan no two both days absolutely Matt yes
and yes and 20 seconds as to why if you
can do one thing after tonight's debate
get hold of a marvelous essay by
Margaret kanavan who sadly passed away
last year and she wrote a really good
piece on the two faces of populism and
the reason I had tell everybody to read
that essay is because can even argued
that we need to stop thinking about
populism as if it's alien to democracy
as if it's a disease that needs to be
cured her thesis was far more compelling
which was that populism is embedded at
the heart of our democratic life you
cannot get rid of populism because it
thrives off of the tensions that exist
between
the politics of skepticism of
managerialism of technocracy and the
politics of faith of redemption of
salvation of taking back control of
making the nation great again and it's
the tension between those two styles
that gives birth to populism time and
time and time again we can't get rid of
it we can only live we only learn sorry
to live with it so I think it will be
around for the rest of our lives and
then some Elise very briefly populism
is going to stay with us for a long time
and actually every case every precedent
that we look at has shown us once they
come to power they do consolidate their
power they do crush civil society and in
the long run they damage democracy and
so it is inherently anti-democratic but
we have to deal with it
I do blame the inequality I do blame the
liberal elite in also the conservative
elite and the populist elite but I don't
blame the university student who might
have a liberal values liberal ideas but
can't even afford her tuition or a
teacher who has liberal values but can't
even you know pay pay her rent these are
the people that we should be very
careful about not blaming and we need to
talk about how the elite have been
disconnected from the real problems of
our times job I want to end on a really
really gloomy note I don't think it's
liberalism or liberals that are
responsible for populism I think it's a
movement of history and that we've had
it good for a very very very long time
through all my lifetime and I'm afraid I
think we are heading into the shadows
much more where people like at like uh
dawuan
are starting to control things much much
more than they have been I hope I'm
wrong but I've got a nasty feeling I'm
right
sweet dreams everybody John Simpson
Alicia [ __ ] that's a good win Daniel
Hannan thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you